party and an elected London assembly
member but less about me because we are
here today to launch our local election
campaign campaign for 2024. so I've got
the wonderful honor of introducing our
brilliant co-leaders Carla Daniel and
Adrian Ramsey
[Applause]
good morning it's such a pleasure to be
in stone market today to launch the
green party local election campaign for
2023.
this is a critical year for us with
hundreds of communities poised to elect
greens to represent them at every level
of local government the last few years
has seen unprecedented success for us
and on the 4th of may we will continue
that historic run in towns and cities
and Villages all over the country greens
are gaining the trust and confidence of
Voters
why because they want something
different from the status quo they want
and we hear this again and again people
that are really listening not taking
their support for granted and going
about business as usual
here in mid-suffolk we're on track to
make history and become the largest
party on the council an incredible feat
and a credit to the Fantastic councilors
we already have working hard for the
people that live here and the candidates
who will join them next month
but this shift is also a credit to the
residents of this County who've asked
for something different and have had
their request answered
sick of the status quo they've called
for a Fresh Approach for people who
listen and act
who have Solutions who get things done
it's no more complex than that
so in Bradford and Leeds in
Hertfordshire and Exeter in Darlington
and South tyneside in all those places
and countless more we're on track for
record success
the country greens are gaining in
and for the benefit of people who live
in all those places we are proud to
announce today one of our key solutions
to a huge problem impacting Millions our
right homes right place right price
Charter
this is a plan to beat the housing
crisis and at the same time to protect
the green spaces we've all come to Value
so much
it's about delivering from Council and
national government level the warm
efficient homes that are so desperately
needed instead of developers being the
winners at every step chasing massive
profits and ignoring local concerns and
needs councils should be in control of
housing building quality affordable
homes in the right place places with the
right infrastructure to make living
there not just bearable but good
so often houses are built that are
completely out of the reach of local
people
what follows is the breakdown of a sense
of community rocketing carbon emissions
local Services unable to cope with
increasing demand
because we shouldn't be building houses
we should be building homes ensuring
their part of communities supported with
facilities like GP surgeries bus
services schools and Leisure centers
making sure that everybody lives within
walking distance from protected Green
Space where children play dogs are walks
and life can be shared and enjoyed
sorry uh all over our country we have
people unable to buy a home trapped in
housing that's unaffordable to rent and
unaffordable to heat
that's why at the green party we would
bring in an immediate rent freeze and
eviction ban
we can't allow people to become homeless
in the middle of a cost of living crisis
and in the longer term we would give
councils the power to bring in rent
controls in areas where the housing
market is overheated
we would also put much stricter controls
on the types of new housing being built
to include more Council homes and more
affordable housing for people buying and
for renters
at the green party we work hard we
believe in tangible action not empty
Concepts And We Believe In fairness
our right homes right place right price
Charter is just one example of how we
put those values into practice
Fair green practical solutions to the
issues we all face in our communities
up and down the country we're gaining
more and more support because people are
looking for something different to the
business as usual approach
greens are winning in all kinds of
communities
what we're hearing in our neighborhoods
is that regardless of where people live
or what they look like they share our
values
they've seen what Greens in their
communities are achieving and they want
more
greens are ready
the people in this room are ready we
will win hundreds of new green
councilors on the 4th of May and then
we'll get to work to make our
communities fairer and Greener thank you
okay thank you very much everyone and
now I think we'll be doing a mixture of
interviews and there'll be opportunities
for more photos and mingling as well
over the next half an hour or so
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you so much sorry no worries